people getting quite nervous about the
rise in covert 19 cases across the uk we
heard from jonathan phantem
one of the country's foremost doctors
talking about this just the other day
um real concerns about how fast these
cases are rising
and so i looked into the numbers to try
and work out you know how worried we
should be
at the moment are there red lights
flashing and this is the chart that
you know a lot of people have been
looking at and saying well this is very
worrying indeed
have a look at this line these bars they
show you the number of new covered 19
cases
we're getting each day and if you look
over on the right hand side
you can see it has risen quite a bit in
the last few weeks in fact the last
three days
up to around three hours 3 000 cases a
day that's the highest that we've seen
since the the kind of period of intense
pandemic
uh back in kind of may so clearly that
is a
cause for concern that those number of
tests uh number of cases are
rising uh to such a high level but
here's the thing period right now is
quite different to the period we had
before
and that's because of this something has
changed we are testing more we're
testing a lot more actually
than we were before a lot more than many
other countries um
and as you have more tests that black
line going up i've just superimposed the
two
on top of each other but as you have
more tests happening
you are more likely to get more positive
results so
really a better measure of the
prevalence of the disease would adjust
for that
and show you the number of positive
cases coming back uh per
test the positivity rate and that's what
i've done here basically
uh got a different chart showing you
that positivity rate
and look it's a very different picture
um down from around
you know in that period kind of april
may one in every three tests was coming
back positive whereas
now it's around one percent now it is up
a bit in the last
few weeks so clearly that is something
that we need to be watching
but it's still only at around the kind
of one percent one point something
percent one point two percent or so
um that's something to keep an eye on
because the minute
you get up to kind of three percent five
percent that's something epidemiologists
are genuinely concerned about
but it's still relatively low so not a
flashing red light on this
this chart which is probably a better
way of measuring uh covert 19
in the country and not a flashing red
light as well when you kind of take that
line we showed you a moment ago this is
just uh
cases again this is a line of the bar
chart i showed you before going up quite
a bit recently
when you compare that to deaths and this
obviously the number of people dying of
diseases
is perhaps the most uh concerning of all
of the statistics that we've covered
over
the past few decades in this country
but have a look at the relationship
between these two lines so early on in
the pandemic
the number of deaths that black line was
rising in lockstep
with the number of cases but have a look
at what's happened more recently the
number of
cases has gone up but that black line
deaths has remained very low in fact the
number of deaths that we've seen
recently is about the lowest it's been
since the the onset of the disease kind
of around
10 maybe 20 a day but low double figures
numbers of deaths higher than anyone
would like but nonetheless lower than
they've been for quite some time
and it does look like there's been a
kind of the relationship between those
two lines has broken down
in a encouraging way now is this just
that we haven't yet seen you know is
there a lag
often you know people get covered 19 it
takes some time before they
face having to go to hospital and some
people sadly die so
are we just seeing a kind of lag and we
will see an impact from this in the next
uh few weeks well that's quite possible
but it so happens that in many other
countries
around europe they saw rises in cases
before the uk so we kind of get a little
sneak preview of what
that lag might actually look like and
the
kind of moderately encouraging thing is
in many of these countries there has
been a rise in cases
but it hasn't necessarily converted to a
big rise in death so this is belgium
so similar chart in this case it cases
per hundred thousand deaths per hundred
thousand
but uh over a seven day period which is
why those lines are a bit smoother but
the important thing is the relationship
between them and look at this again
the black line and the white line so
deaths and cases rising and lockstep
falling in lockstep
and recently case is rising but death's
remaining pretty
low and actually cases coming down uh in
belgium in the day
a couple next few days it might well be
that there is less prevalence of the
disease
per hundred thousand the population than
there is in the uk yet we are imposing
quarantine there's there's some
question marks perhaps about the logic
of that but here we go um
similar picture as well in france so
cases uh look recently
cases rising very sharply deaths are
very low indeed and cases have been
rising for for a good month or so
in france we haven't seen much of an
increase in deaths
again something to keep an eye on
because there are some surgeons talking
about
increased admissions in hospitals but
nonetheless so far
that hasn't converted to the kind of
what we were seeing earlier on in the
pandemic
excuse me a similar thing as well in
germany cases not rising as much but
nonetheless deaths
much lower and in the u.s even though
the pandemic has
been very different in the us much more
intense more people dying
um at least in terms of kind of pure
numbers look
cases that white line still now above
the deaths line whereas you saw more
deaths
uh in the early points of this pandemic
so there is some encouraging news when
you look deeper into the data at this
relationship
and why is that happening that was
entirely sure you know it might be
might it be because the viral load is
lower at the moment so people aren't
getting as much of the disease
might it be that we are getting better
at treating the disease certainly
there's some evidence for that that
people are surviving more in intensive
care
when they come down with this disease so
some encouraging news there
but in practice no one really knows it's
one of the things about covert 19
so many mysteries which is why you know
we just keep looking at the data and
keep
not fixing upon one answer and remaining
relatively open to new explanations as
they come along
and while there are no flashing red
lights clearly uh it's important to be
vigilant about this
vigilance about the rising cases
vigilance it's certainly about the rise
uh in deaths if that does indeed happen
uh and vigilant two about
series like this this shows the number
of people in hospitals
and right now again no flashing red
lights
uh there is not an increase really
there's a slight increase in the last
few days but
nothing like a trend you know more like
noise uh in admissions to
hospital for covert 19 and we need to
keep an eye to
on tests and the number of cases that
are coming back positive because it does
look like it's going up and here's where
the
which the one thing i'm really quite
concerned about over the course of the
past few days it's not just those
overall numbers
it is the fact that there are signs that
the testing system which we were told
was now
you know world class is creaking
uh right now there have been anecdotal
stories i've heard from a few people
in the last few days about them trying
to get a test and not being able to do
so
that's pretty worrying given that we are
seeing cases rising and people are going
to be concerned about
that and you can't get the economy going
again and
have the disease being kind of
commonplace
throughout this country if you're not
able to locate where it is
and if you're not able to trust the
testing system and now we have
official admission from one of the
people in charge sarah jane marsh
that it's not really working very well
right now can i please offer my
heartfelt apologies to anyone who cannot
get a covert 19 test at present
all of our testing sites have capacity
it's our laboratory processing
that's the critical pinch point so
you know in a mission there that the
labs aren't necessarily getting these
tests processed as fast as they should
that they're having real problems
right now i find that really worrying
given that
testing is going to be the absolute
foundation for how the uk deals with
this disease
in the coming months if it doesn't want
to have to go back to nationwide or big
lockdowns so we'll be keeping an eye on
that and how testing is going we'll be
keeping an eye on all of these
statistics over the course
of the next few weeks so far no flashing
red lights but also
no cause for complacency